من خلال ترحيل اكثر من 5000 في فرصه
استثماريه في مختلف الانشطه الاقتصاديه
اشهد ملتقى الاستثمار البلدي بنسخته
الثانيه في الرياض مشاركه عدد من المختصين
والخبراء في المجاري الذين من المقرر ان
يعقد عددا من الجلسات الحواريه وسيوفر
ملتقى الاستثمار البلدي توفير اكثر من 200
منصه مخصصه لعرض المشاريع الناشئه امام
المستثمرين على مدار يومين وبمشاركه عدد
من الامانات البلديه في السعوديه
هذا ما قال خالد الفالح وزير الاستثمار
السعوديه ان حجم الفرص الاستثماريه في
المملكه بحسب الاستراتيجيه الوطنيه
للاستثمار وصل الى 12 ترليون و 400 مليار
ريال وانا نسبه كبيره من هذه الاستثمار
تنفذوا داخل مدن المملكه
من عام 21 من قبل سمو سيدي وانطلقنا في
العمل لها اربع
محاور
رئيسيه اااه المحور الاول في الواقع هو
الفرص الاستثماري
وقدرنا الفرص همم الاستثماريه
ب12.4 مليون ريال سعودي وانا اجزم انه
نسبه كبيره من هذه الاستثمارات
بتكون ان شاء الله في مدن المملكه اللي
كما ذكرت في البدايه هي بوقه اقتصاديه
بقياده معانيه وهمم
وزير الاستثمار السعودي خالد حكى ايضا ان
تركيبه الاستثمار في المدن السعوديه اصبحت
متكامل كامله
في المدن اصبح استثمار متكامل لم يعد
استثمار عقاري بحث
اوصل تستثمر في المدن لازم تفكر بايش
الماكينه الاقتصاديه اللي همم ستكون
موجوده في هذا التجمع في جزء من المدينه
معالي وزير ااا الكوري تكلم عن كيف انه ال
ال السكن في المدن الحديثه المدن الذكيه
بتكون بمبدا لف ورك كم بلاي تعيش تعمل
وتلعب في نفس الحي اللي هو جزء من المدينه
الكبرى قد يكون سكانها 20 30 مليون ولكن
لا تحتاج اكثر من 10 دقائق لقضاء معظم همم
حاجاتك
من ملتقى الاستثمار البلدي فرص في الرياض
ينضم الينا مراسل العربيه عبد المحسن
الحربي عبد المحسن مرحبا بك اهم ما يناقشه
هذا الملتقى واهم الفعاليات المقامه ايضا
على هامشي معي
اداره المدن واستثمارها وتقويه المدن
وايضا ادارتها على مستوى الاقتصادي وتمكين
اقتصاديا لكي ااه تدير نفسها او تعزز من
امكانيات الاقتصاديه لتضخ الاموال من جديد
في داخل هذه المدن هي ابرز ما يتم مناقشته
اليوم في هذا ملتقى الذي يطرح اكثر من
خمسه الاف فرصه لدى المستثمرين الكثير من
الدعوات التي اطلقت اليوم لكل المستثمرين
سواء كان على مستوى الصغار المستثمرين او
حتى الكبار المستثمرين لتلقي هذه الفرص في
الملتقى اوصل نتحدث اكثر خالد مع المشرف
العام عن الملتقى همم فرص وهو الاستاذ
خالد الدغيثر وكيل وزاره
تتحدث عن هذا الملتقى في عام الثاني
طرحتهم اكثر من خمسه الاف فرصه حدثنا عن
هذه الفرصه عن القطاعات وعن ابرز المستهدف
من خلال هذه الفرص حياك الله طبعا الملتقى
يهدف الى
الجاذبيه اثمار في المدن وتحفيز ثمرات
المحليه واستخطاب استمارات خارجيه تنمل
المدن في مختلف القطاعات يتكون
الملتقى من جلسات حواريه يمكن حواريه
اليوم اللي كانت برئاسه المعالي كانت جلسه
وزاريه كان فيها معالي الوزير ومعالي
الوزير استثمار ومعالي وزير النقل ومعالي
وزير صناعه وكذلك ورش عمل ورش عمل وكذلك
معرض مصاحب اليوم الملتقى هو حاضن لعدد
كبير من الفرصها عدد كبير من الجهات سواء
في القطاع الرياضي في القطاع البلدي في
القطاع السياحي اليوم العراق في الثمار
رحلته في الملتقى من خلال وجود الفرصه
معرفه اليه الوصول للفرس
وجود القناه تمويليه وايضا معرفه اليات
التنظيم معنا في الملتقى في هذا العام
تشارك دوله قطر كمدينه ضيف لعرض نجاح
تجربتها في كاس العالم مع ان في هذا
الملتقى تشارك انديه رياضيه مثل هلال
النصر الشباب لعرض توجهات الاستثماريه مع
ان في هذه الملتقى شركه سفن تعرض ايضا
توجهاتها اليوم في تنميه المدن وجعلها
وجهات سياحيه مع ان اليوم في هذا الملتقى
ايضا حديقه الملك سلمان اليوم صندوق
التنميه السياحي
للمشاريع السياحيه لتفعيل واجهات سياحيه
اليوم ملتقى هو حاضن لجهود جهات عديده
وليس فقط غطاء بلدي وباذن الله يحقق
اهدافه اذا ممكن تتحدث عن هذه المنصه
وابرز الارقام تتحدث على اكثر من سنتين او
اكثر من اطلاقها ما هي ابرز الارقام التي
تم تحقيقهم خلال هذه المنصه التي تتوفر
فيها الفرص في الاستثمار البلدي طبعا همم
كلمه فرص في ملتقى فرص وفي بوابه
ملتقى فرسه والملتقى لان احنا الان فيه
والبوابه هي البوابه الالكترونيه من خلال
ما يتم طرح العديد من الفرص المريه على
مستوى قطاع البلدي والان اصبحت على مستوى
جميع الجهات حكوميه للفرص العقاريه التي
طرحت جميع جهه حكوميه
فيعجبه الفرق بين المنصه كبوابه او كم
ملتقى
العدد الفرص الفرص بالالاف يمكن اليوم مع
الوزير ان عقود ملياريه وقعت من خلال هذه
منصه واعتقد انه ملتقى اليوم خلال اليومين
القادمه سيشهد توقي عدم اتفاقيات والعقود
التي تنعكس ايجابا على تنميه المدن يمكن
مثلا في شيء ودي اعرج على اليوم عدد
الحضور للمتقد تجاوز 24,000 خلال ساعات
الحمد لله وجدنا اقبال وجدنا شهيه كبيره
للاستثمار في المدن السعوديه وجدنا حرص
كبير على حضور ست حواريه والاستفاده من
ورش العمل كذلك
يشارك في الملتقى عدد كبير من رواد
ورايدات الاعمال لعرض يعني تم توفير اكثر
من 200 منصه لرواد اداره الاعمال لعرض
مشاريعهم الرائده كذلك تم توفير اكثر موجه
لاكثر من موجه
لجلوس جلسات النهائيه مع رواد الاعمال
للخروج لتوجيههم شكرا لكم طال عمرك اذا
خالد كما تشاهد هذا الملتقى الذي يستمر
حتى يوم بعد غدا ويستخدم الكثير من رواد
الاعمال
والالاف من الفرص التي تطرح وايضا العديد
من التصريحات همم في كافه القطاعات الاخرى
اليوم تم الحديث عن الجسر البري من قبل
وزير النقل والذي قال بان 11 شركه تقوده
شركه صينيه وفي مراحل متقدمه ايضا المناطق
اللوجستيه الاخرى الكثير من التصريحات
التي يتم همم طرحها من خلال هذا الملتقى
الذي يجمع بين المستثمرين وكذلك الفرص
التي تطرحها الامانات والجهات الحكوميه
المختلفه